this is Philipe he's working at
booking.com as a machine learning
scientist and he will today talk about
how to use business metrics instead of
traditional machine learning metrics for
his machine learning models so give him
a warm welcome Philipe thank
you great thank you everyone for coming
to my talk um well I'd like to introduce
myself for people that don't know me I'm
a machine learning scientist at
booking.com um where I specialize in
uplift modeling and College of machine
learning I I work in the smart benefits
team in Booking insight's pricing
Department before booking I was a PhD in
Del for those that hasn't been there
it's really a really nice city um I'm
also Co organizing of the mlops
community I'm Sadam so if you want to
know more about it please uh well shout
me out on LinkedIn or send me my email
we have um tce every every two months
meetups focus on ML and mlops um
so the agenda for today is I'm going to
cover four points for you I'm going to
talk about ML and business metrics and
what are the problem with them um then
I'm going to give a brief introduction
how you do offline evaluation and online
evaluation and some approaches that we
can use uh very simple approaches in
machine learning by using this business
Matrix and then I'm going to go over a
pratical use case at booking.com at we
my team we use uplift
modeling um before going through my
first slides I'm going to acknowledge in
this in this conference we had four nice
talks that you can also watch it later
about on the same topics um so all
around College ml so you can also follow
this and I really like those STS so
going to shout to these people there
well first let's start with the ML and
business Matrix and there's two high
trops for you today as a a data science
orl practitioner and as well your
stakeholders might might have here is
that most of the times practitioners
they care too much about ml metrics and
you have too many of them right so many
times we are there trying to model our
problems and we are just focusing on
those metrics and suddenly we we want to
deploy our models and well what they
actually our stakeholders care about are
the business metrics and what are those
business metrics most of the times we we
they're looking for are directly
increasing their profits or long-term
value in the customers and well and this
uh can be directly increasing sales
conversion rates or cutting
costs um but also indirectly where we
want to increase higher C satisfaction
and finding the right
product and this is the our Ro as a ml
practitioner we go over all these plots
in a hyper per 20 try to find all the
best models all using metrics like log
loss hyper Precision Au right and what
our stakeholders want us to go is to go
over the business metric and find the
best model if you have all these
possibilities of these models based on
the business metrics how can we close
this Gap right so this is what I want to
talk about this
talk so for ML System model to and
system to succeed we need to tie the
performance of the ml system and the
overall business
metric and how to do so well sometimes
it can be simple sorry about it um ex
examples is one of them here is at to
rate prediction where if we increase the
our Precision in this system this ml
system we we we may increase is ADD
Revenue right um and another example
which is simple to tie is fra detection
where if you increase sometimes the
Precision of the of the of the fraud
detection model you might actually save
cost to the business and those are well
you can actually map directly the M
metric and the business
metric unfortunately this is not for all
ml systems and all ml problems here I sh
you an example for my problem I'm show
you later in this presentation where if
you look to the ml Matrix and the
business Matrix they don't correlate
that strongly especially for a very
strongl metrics like log loss for
classification where in my my case it
doesn't it doesn't show that is very
high correlated to that to that model
that this is sucks and we we really want
to to also close this Gap right and our
stakeholders really want us to do to do
this um so How We Do evaluation using
those business matrics typically we want
to observe this improvements in those
business metrics and in we to mirror
what we call offline evaluation to the
online evaluation and at booking we do
the of course with AB testing so
typically we have your Baseline system
that has been running production and you
want to test out a new model
so this is what we and then we we also
have in some systems where we have the
control traffic where we use this most
for the caal ml models which is
typically the the problem we face in
when you're trying to measure some of
this business
metrix um this all these three sets are
what we call online evaluation so we
wanted if you deploy our model we are
reserving this metrics right um but in
sometimes you actually can look at the
offline evaluation and only look to
these two first sets to derive what
would be uh our results on this business
Matrix before deploying a new
model um well given this set we can
answer questions right what would be the
change in the business Matrix if I
deploy this new model how much cost will
this model save if I compare with the
model that is in production or maybe if
a control with with with the no traffic
that has no model to it um how much
increasing conversion I'm going to have
and how much return increasing in return
investment and on some of these indirect
profit Matrix can to measure in offline
manner right so increasing customer
satisfaction active customers those
those metrics are
not PR for this for for this offline
setup therefore we need actually need
more more robust or more efficient
online evaluation and for example using
context Bandits a nice paper from my
colleagues at booking is this one here
from Europe in 2021 so if you want to
know more about it also um U take a
read and now I want to go over how can
we actually use this offline evaluation
setup and using those of this offline
evaluation setup to optimizing uh for
our business metrics to simple
techniques that I have used in this
project is in early stop in hyper per T
optimization um most of the times we
only look to these two techniques by
only the eyes of ml metrix right I want
to give you point of view how can you do
this techniques using business metrics
as well um for those who don't know the
early stopping is typically where we try
to train our models and we stop this
model before we actually don't don't
observe any improvement over some
validation set right um so this is the
typical curves that we look if you look
to the ml metric or the loss then you
stop it at some point that you don't see
any Improvement this this also can be
your business metric right you can also
stop your model training on this on this
business metric at the point that we
don't deserve this Improvement so most
of the times we don't we don't do this
and this is some something simple that
can be
done so what would be the benefits for
overall of the of the early stopping
right you can generalize your new data U
improve over feting over feting and also
save a lot of time and and and resources
from from you as a as a practition
um and can be used in several families
of models right so in new networks we
see this in number of epo I mean the
size of data set you have and in gring
boost machines like hbm these a number
of iterations and trees that you have in
your model right so you might want to
have simple models based on your
business metric you don't need you to go
further if your business metric is not
impr
proven um one that is more I I like more
which is hyper
optimization and as again we here is
actually we're trying to find the best
combination of the hyper parameters your
models right and and we do that uh still
with the male metric and not with the
business metric so and just to point out
that there are two simple techniques
that most we we do it grid search and
runal search and and those are are
techniques that we can find the the the
business mattress uh as best model
business metric of the sets now these
techniques can be inefficient for high
high dimension in spaces like trees or
um gr boost machines where you have too
many hyper parameters to try out um and
you you that's going to guarantee that
you're going to find the opto model um
doing your doing your
search um well the main problem of this
with this grid search and that it NE
negret the prior evaluations right of
your
as you're searching
and one Tech set of family of techniques
that goes over try to solve this problem
is sequential model optimization and
first start with Bas on optimization
where you have a hyper parameter that
you're searching for and you have a
performance of your model for that
specific hyper parameter and on this
prior optimizations and then you can
Feit um a new model over trying to find
what would be your hyper how would be
your performance of your model give for
that specific
hyperparameter and then we use this this
prediction to find the new hyper paramet
that we can search for and then this
performance again can be both a your
male metric but as well your business
metrics that you're looking for right um
now what I found my pring is the we call
the three parts approximation where that
way we we are are using
[Music]
currently and I'm going to go a bit
deeper on this on this so the idea of of
this is instead of modeling the your
what would be your performance of your
of your of your model giving some haror
parameters you you your model what would
be your haror parameter and and what if
you find the performance of it so you
the pi Dex giv I and for for doing this
the this these three parts of should go
for two sorate models so you first look
for trying to find the the good group of
hyper parameters the good group of uh
range of hyper parameters and the the B
group so we going to now we going to
estimate these two groups instead of uh
um just one two two models instead of
one
and and how we Define this is we we we
need to find a threshold what you define
as a as a hyper parameter of your hper
tning um where you define what would be
the good and the
bad um well and simply new promising
hyper parameters can be based on on the
expected improvements measure which is
the division of the two
probabilities um here in visualization
how you typically do this while while
you're searching for the best hyper
parameters on the the plot on the on on
the top you you see that as you search
you keep you keep looking for the good
group right so then you are able to find
the range of your hyperparameter on this
new group um this Pro is not mine so it
is a it's a plot made by cril
engineering which I find very intuitive
uh to to understand this and this in
this blog POS really um explain quite
well uh these
techniques
um well giving this two set of
techniques I want to show how I use this
in my in my practical use case and here
is uplift modeling at booking.com uh
uplift modeling aims to find what would
be the most power impact that you have
uh of the cause impact of your of your
treatment can be a promotion in this
case in the difference of of this with
and without that promotion um what we're
looking at is to build two models where
one is actually try to predict what
would be the conversion of of this of
this customer giv that we provide the
promotion and what would be the
conversion without the promotion um in
this project we use a little trick that
we call with rospective estimation where
we convert this classification problem
with just one model well which means
that instead of predicting the
conversion we go and predict the
promotion probabilities giving a
customer giv that he's already going to
uh convert and if you know want to know
about this take a look at the Freel
lunch r perspective Li modeling for
paper that we have in Rex 2020
my and how you provide the this this
problem how you evaluate this model uh
in offline manner look at you we first
look at your your traffic for for the
treatment which means that a treatment
where you give a promotion to everyone
this is typically done and you saw a
case uh here in in this this conference
from Uber as well that they also do the
same
where you have a traffic your your your
of your customers that you always
provide a promotion and then you also
have a traffic That You observe which is
the control if you remember the two the
two sets that I showed in the beginning
of the stock this is the the the the the
the left and the right the first two
left
sets and based on this on on the on the
treatment that I already know which
people that I should give promotion I
try to predict what what would be the
the highest probability of I should give
promotion to some of these of these
customers and I would pick some of this
customers to give actually the promotion
in on online and this is where where
where it comes uh the offline evaluation
so this is I'm looking at the everyone
that I have already provide a promotion
and I'm actually now sing part of these
people that and in a Sim you can think
this as an simulation as well and it can
compute this marginal return of
investment or other business metrics
that you you you care
about um just a quick uh Tech more like
techno here is well this for this
example I'm showing is a data set of
more than 30 million rows we typically
trip uh uh split is in time stamp Manner
and we we like lbm as I have been
talking so many in this talk so we go
for lbm binary classifier and I look for
six hper parment tonies to find the best
models of
them my my experimental here is going to
be on on the random search where I my
hper per 20 metric is going to be three
the log loss every Precision in business
metric and I go for a Bas optimization
for TP uh with uh three metrics and the
last one I want to try out is the full
business metric um where I do early
stopping on the business measure but as
well the hyper perameter tuning all
these experiments I we use uh one 1,000
trios using optuna Library which is a
very nice uh python library for hyper
permited tuning um if you have a use in
your projects I really recommend it very
robust and can really scale scale on
your
project first I want to look at the
hyper parameter T results specifically
comparing
here what would be for theil Matrix what
would be the impact of using based
optimization versus random search and
what would we would expect that we once
we do hyper using TP we often find the
best model earlier and this means that
instead of going for 1,000 trios it
typically you really can go much shorter
and might really save a lot of a lot of
time rather just do random search on on
on your models on the ml metric what is
most more interesting is going for the
business metric right where if I go for
run search on the business metric I
would go to find the best model on very
very late and typically having observing
is that once you use some Bas
optimization on the business metric um
you can do it much earlier this is a
again some results for this use case I'm
showing that we we have at booking
so as a as a hyper per using business
matx helps finds the this much easier
much earlier
right and now how about the early
stopping well the early stopping goes
it's really is really finding the best
model in the be very beginning of your
trials and this scared me a little bit
when I looked at these models I saw that
the early stopping on the business
Matrix then to bring simpler models uh
with the best results on the on the
business Matrix doing the have peret 20
now looking at these results uh overall
right it's not just looking the of the
of the hyper per 20 results looking for
the offline evaluation results that I
show uh uh I talk you about is you get
all this model this model and on the on
the Y AIS you look at your business
metric what would be it and the tra and
the X uh access is the traffic how much
people you're reading to offer promotion
um you see that this this models are
behav quite similar with the exception
of the actually using full full business
which is the or stopping in the in the
hyper perameter
tuning um what is more important is that
if you look at the area under the
business matric we can summarize these
models the the the ones that are very
close by and it's hard to visualize um
where the if if you look at the the TP
which is the the the more de basion
optimization style uh is is goes on
comes on top and after the random search
why I put it on top because it it help
us stops much earlier doing the doing
the
training so what would be here the the
take-home message for for this for for
this uh for this stock right we saw that
how important is to tie the business
metric and the ml metric um we saw
techniques that we can optimize machine
learning models using business metrix
and Hyper T optimization we using R
search is time consuming so TP can speed
up your Hyun
automization we also saw that the
business metric uh helped to find
terminated hyperon earlier and early
stopping using bu met do not bring the
best model always what you do next in
your your your project right well you
can use those those techniques in your
your your business problem right so you
I'm really curious to know if you you
also face the same problem um do you
also always have to deploy your model do
you also see less Improvement in the
business metric even with the best ml
metric uh well you can try out such a
more techniques pruning is very very
nice I really want to go deeper in it at
sometimes later on in my projects and
maybe you have two business metrics and
you can and you can actually useing
hyper per optimization with multiple
metrics um I like to to thanks the the
smart benefits team so this project
might be done without them and thank you
for listening and if you have any
questions thank you pH